willkommen an der
teresa militärakademie in österreich ich bin carl marcos reisner
der leiter der forschungs- und
entwicklungsabteilung der akademie und heute
werden wir uns erstmal
mit kognitiver kriegsführung,
dem krieg in der ukraine und dem verborgenen kampf
um unseren gedanken befassen
Schauen wir uns die
traditionellen Bereiche der Kriegsführung an,
wir haben den Landbereich, den maritimen
Bereich und natürlich wird der Luftbereich
immer wichtiger, der
Weltraumbereich,
aber interessant ist, dass es zwei
Bereiche gibt, die
die anderen immer mehr dominieren, und das ist
die Cyberdomäne, weil
sie alle anderen mehr oder weniger
fast gleichzeitig durchläuft, und natürlich ist es die
Informationsdomäne, die Domäne, an der wir alle
teilnehmen,
wenn wir uns die Art der Kriegsführung
ansehen, dann können wir sehen, dass es eine
Transformation von der traditionellen gibt
mechanisierte kriegsführung
über informationsgestützte kriegsführung in
richtung intelligente kriegsführung was bedeutet
es bedeutet,
dass alle mittel, die wir haben, wenn es
um digitalisierung geht  gibt uns die
Möglichkeit, unseren
Geist mit allen Mitteln und durch die
Kontrolle der Informationen, die wir konsumieren, immer mehr zu kontrollieren,
wenn Sie sich im Detail ansehen und
sich bestimmte Begriffe wie hybride
Kriegsführung, kognitive Kriegsführung, Informationskrieg
und Cyberkrieg ansehen, können wir sehen,
dass es eine gibt  eine mischung aus bestimmten
dingen in der mitte dieser drei
kreise, die die möglichkeit definiert, einen
anderen gegner anzugreifen, indem man
einflussoperationen durchführt,
wenn wir uns jetzt den konflikt in der ukraine ansehen, ist
es interessant zu sehen,
dass der beginn des konflikts
nicht nur durch all das repräsentiert wurde  Dinge, die
wir am Boden gesehen haben, also die Panzer
und die Infanterie-Kampffahrzeuge und
die angreifenden Flugzeuge, aber auch durch
viele andere Dinge, die verborgen waren, zum
Beispiel
all die Cyber-Angriffe, die
vor Beginn der Feindseligkeiten und
danach durchgeführt wurden, und so weiter  interessant zu sehen,
dass vor allem die russische seite versuchte
, die ukrainischen soldaten aktiv zu beeinflussen,
wie sie das taten
also werfen wir einen blick auf den anfang
am 24.
februar am anfang lag viel fokus auf
kiew und der situation dort die luft wurde
von den russischen truppen auf kiew verkauft
aber parallel zu diesen entwicklungen sendeten
russische drohnen kurze nachrichten
an die ukraine  soldaten
im osten sagten ihnen, dass
die regierung und die militärische
führung gestürzt seien.
die ukrainische seite kämpfte eine zeitlang
darum, ihnen zu verstehen zu geben, dass
alles in ordnung sei und dass sie immer
noch gegen die russische seite kämpfen,
aber dies ist ein klares beispiel für
einflussoperationen  Von russischer Seite durchgeführt ist
es auch interessant zu sehen, dass die
russische Seite in der Lage war
, Multi-Domain-Operationen durchzuführen
, also Cyber-Operationen in
Verbindung mit physischen Angriffen durch
Raketen zum Beispiel, wie wir hier
in mehreren Beispielen im März sehen können,
interessant ist das in  die andauernde
Phase bedeutet angesichts dessen, wo wir uns
derzeit befinden,
gewisse Institutionen wie der russische
Minister  auswärtige angelegenheiten oder der
russische verteidigungsminister, aber auch die
geheimdienste wie die gru, der
svr und der fsb
versuchen aktiv, uns zu beeinflussen.
diese institutionen verwenden
verschiedene formate, medienformate,
um die westliche welt zu beeinflussen, um sicherzustellen
, dass sie nicht alles verstehen,
was  Sie können im Fernsehen sehen, dass es echt ist. Ich
möchte Ihnen das folgende
Video zeigen. Das Video zeigt
offensichtlich getötete ukrainische Soldaten, aber
wenn Sie sich das Ende des Videos
ansehen, können Sie sehen, dass diese Soldaten rennen und
wegziehen  Abnutzung
wird nicht auf dem Schlachtfeld entschieden,
sondern an der Heimatfront,
also müssen wir verstehen, dass es einen
Kampf gegen uns gibt,
wenn ich mich auf uns beziehe, dann meine ich die
westliche Welt,
also lassen Sie uns noch einmal im Detail
über den Zustand der sprechen  konflikt für
die bewegung haben wir einen
zermürbungskrieg, also gibt es erfolge von der ukrainischen seite in calzone und natürlich auch
inkas in khakis,
aber die qu  Die Frage ist, ob die Entscheidung
des Konflikts
wirklich auf dem Schlachtfeld oder vielleicht an
der Heimatfront getroffen wird. Was meine ich
damit, dass die russische Seite versucht,
uns an der Heimatfront zu beeinflussen
, indem sie uns solche Geschichten erzählt?
das Problem mit Getreide, wir werden eine
Hunger- oder sogar Massenmigrationssituation haben,
dass wir aufgrund der Saporosie-Situation
und natürlich vielleicht des Einsatzes taktischer
Raketen eine nukleare
Katastrophe haben werden, und insgesamt gibt es die
Angst
aus dem Westen, dass es vielleicht so etwas geben wird
des wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruchs in
naher zukunft, weil russland uns
nicht die ressourcen geben wird, die wir brauchen, um den winter zu überstehen,
und wie wir in den
medien sehen können, werden all diese operationen von
russischer seite mit
schlagzeilen wie zum beispiel
der kritischen gasversorgung europas gefüttert
oder
es ist interessant zu sehen, dass Gasprom, nachdem es
tatsächlich den
Gasfluss durch North Stream One gestoppt hat,
unmittelbar danach das
Video veröffentlicht hat, das wir gerne hätten  Ihnen zu zeigen,
was dem Westen zeigt, was mit ihnen passieren wird
, weil das Gas
nicht nach Westen fließt
[Musik]
Ich
ja
[Musik]
Das Problem ist, dass es so aussieht, als
wären die Europäer nicht so freundlich  Von
Widerstandsfähigen wie vielleicht den Russen
gab es 2015 eine Umfrage und es wurde
die Frage gestellt, ob Sie bereit wären
, für Ihr Land zu kämpfen,
und Sie können sehen, dass der
Wille in den westeuropäischen Ländern sehr gering ist,
in den Vereinigten Staaten und in Australien ist er anders
Natürlich ist es in China
und sogar in Russland anders
und natürlich, wie Sie hier sehen können,
weil dies 2015 geschah, also nach
dem Angriff
der russischen Ukraine im Jahr 2014, ist es
in der Ukraine noch höher,
aber dies ist das Terrain, das von
der russischen Seite genutzt wird  greifen uns mit diesen
Einflussoperationen an,
so dass vielleicht eine Situation, wie
wir sie mit dem Denken
der Quadratischsten gesehen haben,
wo wir denken, dass es ein großer Erfolg war, dazu
führt, dass die
Russen noch entschlossener werden  ined, weil
sie sagen, dass wir jetzt gegen den Westen kämpfen,
aber auf der anderen Seite
sagen uns unsere Medien, dass die Situation noch
schlimmer ist, als wir denken,
und vielleicht
werden die Wiedervereinigungen ohne die Suche und militärische Hilfe
nicht möglich sein  lösen,
oder wir sind vielleicht nicht in der Lage,
alle Waffen aufzubringen, die die Ukrainer
brauchen, weil wir immer noch
in der
Waffenproduktion Stückwerk sind
oder natürlich in
der Sanktionsfrage, die
uns offensichtlich mehr schmerzt als Russland, zumindest das  ist,
was russland uns zu sagen versucht,
also müssen wir uns fragen,
ob
erfolge wie
beim angriff auf die krim auf dem flugplatz saki,
der sehr erfolgreich war,
oder bei den operationen
der ukrainischen seite
in kerasone
oder  selbst in hakeef könnte dazu
führen,
dass russland die situation,
die wir in den letzten zwei tagen gesehen haben, eskaliert,
weil die russen begonnen haben,
die kritische infrastruktur
von th anzugreifen  Das Land muss natürlich Druck
auf die westliche Hilfe für die Ukraine ausüben. In
diesem kurzen Video können Sie das
Ergebnis eines dieser Angriffe auf das ukrainische
Kraftwerk sehen. Daher ist
es wichtig zu verstehen, dass die
Ukraine die Unterstützung des Westens braucht
, um gegen Russland zu kämpfen  braucht
die waffen wie die, die wir hier sehen,
um gegen russland zu kämpfen, das ihr
schwerpunkt ist, also versucht russland
alles
, um den schwerpunkt zu verringern,
um die hilfe des westens für die ukraine zu verringern.
die erzählungen, die die ukrainer
dafür verwenden, sind sehr einfach  erstens
verteidigt die ukraine europa gegen die
russische aggression und die ukraine verteidigt
oder westliche werte im kampf gegen
die russen
auf der anderen seite werfen wir einen blick auf
den schwerpunkt der russischen
gesellschaft
es ist der zusammenhalt des russischen
volkes und das zusammenhalten  Mit
dem Präsidenten sind ihre Erzählungen
anders als bei uns.
Sie haben die Erzählung, es ist nicht Russland
gegen die Ukraine, nein,
es ist nicht  er west die us nato europa gegen
uns
wir kämpfen einen krieg wie unsere
großeltern es ist ein großer vaterländischer
krieg 2.0
im nächsten video sehen sie ein
beispiel dieser russischen propaganda
und wie das russische volk damit arbeitet
[musik]
[musik
] Das Risiko besteht also darin, dass die Ukraine vielleicht
auf dem Schlachtfeld gewinnt, wie
wir hier in der
Hakeef-Offensive gesehen haben,
aber die Entscheidung, wie dieser Konflikt
enden wird, wird vielleicht nicht in der Ukraine selbst getroffen,
sondern in unseren Heimatländern,
weil es davon abhängt
Hilfe von uns für die Ukrainer, und
wir sollten nicht vergessen, dass es nicht überall auf
der Welt Hilfe für die
Ukraine gibt, weil viele Teile der
Welt noch
in der Schwebe sind und abwarten, was sie in den
nächsten Monaten
tun sollen, also stellt sich die Frage, wie wir es tun sollen  Gehen Sie
in diesem Konflikt vor,
es ist wie eine Spielrechnung, also gibt es ein
Kartenspiel zwischen dem Westen und Russland.
In diesem Kartenspiel haben wir verschiedene
Karten, also
gibt es die Diplomatenkarte, es gibt die
Informationskarte, also k  Was passiert jetzt
hinter den Kulissen
und natürlich ist es die Karte von Militär
und Wirtschaft.
Das Kartenspiel wurde von der russischen Seite gestartet.
Die russische Seite hat eine Militärkarte benutzt
und die Ukraine angegriffen. Wir waren
schockiert, was
wir getan haben
sanktionen gegen russland, aber es sieht so aus, als ob
diese sanktionen zeit brauchen
,
um auf russischer seite wirklich zu wirken, während
die russen ihre
wirtschaftskarte benutzen, weil
sie versuchen, uns zu drohen,
dass sie immer mehr reduzieren
äh  die ressourcen, die wir von ihnen haben, also ist
die situation so, dass wir immer noch
wissen,
dass noch viel
mehr kommen wird, und wie hier geschrieben steht,
gibt es sehr wahrscheinlich einen angespannten druck auf
die europäische gesellschaft, und wie wir
hier in der tschechischen republik sehen können  und in deutschland
gibt es schon einige proteste, die
eine kürzung der hilfe
durch grün fordern
und es sieht so aus, als müssten wir
vielleicht harte entscheidungen treffen und wieder i
h  Ich möchte
von ukrainischer Seite betonen, dass
der Bedarf an Waffen derzeit noch hoch ist, aber
vielleicht wird die Entscheidung in Bezug auf den
Konflikt in unseren
Heimatländern getroffen, wenn es um die Frage
geht, ob wir der Ukraine weiter helfen sollen oder
nicht  wenn man zu dem schluss kommt, dass der krieg in der
ukraine auf mehreren
ebenen geführt wird, ist die eine ebene die taktische
operative ebene
auf dem schlachtfeld in der ukraine, aber die
andere ebene ist die strategische ebene,
die bedeutet, russland gegen die ukraine zu bekämpfen,
aber vor allem die unterstützung
des westens  zur ukraine können wir resümieren,
dass es noch nicht vorbei ist und dass
die nächsten wochen und monate
insbesondere die
winterzeit entscheidend für die ukraine sein werden
, damit beschließt unser brief für heute und
ich möchte mich ganz nebenbei bei ihnen bedanken und alles
gute  Ich möchte ein ganz
besonderes Dankeschön für meine besonderen
Fans aussprechen. Einige von ihnen denken sogar,
dass ich ein russischer Agent bin. Es wäre
interessant zu definieren,
welche Organisation ich bin.  ich arbeite für
ist es der svr oder der fsb oder ist es
der außenminister oder sogar
der verteidigungsminister
ich möchte mich auch bei
all denen bedanken, die mir
über 80 pro woche von jung an spam-e-mails schicken
Damen, die mit mir Kontakt aufnehmen möchten,
kann ich leider nicht beantworten. Damit ist
mein Briefing abgeschlossen, und ich danke
Ihnen sehr, dass Sie uns zugehört haben